[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
tick tock tick tock there's a lot of
clocks ticking a lot of clocks talking
oh
I don't know I said on St Patrick's Day
that Donald Trump's luck seems to be
running out and uh here we are again oh
my gosh look at that
what the hell is wrong with me
yeah dropping the ball already today
I I swear I didn't have that much to
drink last night usually I I do drink on
Wednesdays that's my uh it's my fun day
and so sometimes I am a little uh Sauced
here on Thursday mornings but that is
not the case this morning that was just
a complete mistake
that happens sometimes I don't know I
just I I prefer to be honest with the
audience tell them the truth absolutely
on Wednesdays
I have a little bit of Jagermeister
that's my Jagermeister day so you know
what are you gonna do some people have
their vices I have mine on Wednesdays
what's it to you
but that has nothing to do with the
mistake I just made on screen okay let's
get back to business here
Donald Trump
luck is running out
um the the Manhattan DA's grand jury is
delayed again today
it's um very curious why it's delayed
not really sure why some people are
speculating lots of different things
right I mean it could be it could be
that I don't know it could be
that there's threats I mean we've seen
the other day there was a bomb threat in
in
New York City as a judge gambled down
the Civil hearing for uh tis James gonna
tear apart the Trump organization so
that happened maybe it's security
threats maybe just maybe
there's something to Trump's lawyer
appearing today and then possibly
tomorrow now the word is is that Trump's
attorney is peering today to defend
Trump's case with the Mike's Pence
subpoena from Jack Smith tomorrow he's
gonna go
testify against Donald Trump this is
some weird [__] man
what the f what the [__] I mean here's
the thing
if your attorney
in the criminal case that the attorney
is defending you against
is compelled to testify against you
I you're [__] right I mean am I am I
am I off my rocker I don't know I maybe
I'm yeah I'm nuts here it just feels
like to me that none of this is good for
Donald Trump right now the other the
other thing too is yesterday uh you saw
Donald Trump Jr I posted it I I tweeted
at him and [__] idiot
uh Donald Trump Jr posted a letter from
another attorney saying oh Donald Trump
committed no crime look there's no
[__] difference in one attorney
writing a letter that Donald Trump
didn't commit crime then Donald Trump
[__] absolutely losing his goddamn
gourd on fraud social in all caps
calling Alvin Bragg the Manhattan D.A
this morning a Soros bought
animal
our sorrows backed animal I don't
remember the exact name he called him an
animal
now
some people were pointing out to me
because I said it's anti-semitic come on
he's he's saying Jew is what he's saying
now some people pointed out to me that
animal may be derogatory towards Alvin
Bragg's race but you got to remember who
Donald Trump is talking to right this is
what you have to remember about this
you have to remember that he's talking
to white supremacist Donald Trump cult
members the moglodytes the real America
verse Nazi party this is very important
this language listen Nazis in this
country know Alvin Bragg is black
and they know in their minds in their
minds he's a hard R so I mean maybe just
maybe when he's calling Alvin bragged
Soros backed animal maybe he's calling
him a Jewish hard R but he definitely
definitely is pointing out that Alvin
Bragg
somehow is Jewish
it's weird stuff it's weird stuff now
there is a documentary out there on
Netflix
um and I rewatched it the other day I
re-watched I've watched this documentary
several times
this documentary is very interesting
um and the reason why this documentary
is very interesting is because it was
made in 1973 I believe
is when the documentary was made
now this documentary is called Hitler a
career
that's what it's called you can go on
Netflix and you can you can find it you
can probably find it even out there on
the internet because again it's it's an
old documentary this documentary is from
back in 1970s
but that's very important
when you watch this documentary here's
the reason why this documentary I
believe is so important to watch
if you're not gonna go read books or you
know take a four-year study course
on 1920s 30s and 40s Germany and the
second world war this documentary I
believe is the one to watch it's it's
sort of boring it's not
um it's not really
how do I want to put it because it's a
lot it's it's video that Hitler and the
Nazis took themselves and they compile
it and they tell the story of Hitler
from the time that he began until his
demise until he ate an ammo sandwich
now the reason why it's important that
it was made in 1973
is because of the lens that you looked
through in 1973 at Nazi Germany
1970s there was
there was no
there there was no 1980s cold war to end
to the cold war war that the fall of the
wall as it were Mr Gorbachev tear down
this wall
there was no there was no Gulf Wars
there was there was no 911
there was no right-wing talk radio there
was no Fox News
there was no oan or Newsmax or trumpism
as it were today or this make America
great again
hell there there wasn't even the supply
side economics that we went through in
the 80s and we still suffer from today
where the rich get richer and the one
percent is protected by the politicians
who they pay
that wasn't the world that we lived in
1973 was a completely different world
and that is why it's so important to go
watch this particular documentary
so important because of the the lens
that they looked through in 1970s at
Nazi Germany
and you'll know what I mean when I want
when you watch it you'll know exactly
what I mean you'll be like well good God
damn because again they're not speaking
to
comparing Nazi Germany
to the last 30 years the last 30 years
didn't play a part in that documentary
it hadn't happened yet
and I I know it feels like should I Tony
should I really go watch a documentary
on Hitler should I yes you absolutely
should you should show it to anyone you
can show it to
and this documentary is called Hitler a
career
and it sounds like it first you know I
know I know it sounds like At first that
oh this is this is really going to to
idolize Hitler
go watch it go watch it
just go watch it
and again it's not the most it's it's
not the most fantastic documentary I've
ever seen
doesn't like keep you on edge it's not
like a crime drama or I am a killer or
or you know some sort of murder mystery
that's not what it is
it just lays out the facts of what
Hitler did and what the Nazis did
to draw Nazi Germany into fascism
and what the road map was
and how he worked himself into position
to be there fear her their God their
Jesus
their savior
their retribution
I'm not [__] you and and this
documentary plays several of Hitler's
speeches
and you listen to his language and he
listened to his rhetoric
and this this rhetoric of Alan Alvin
Bragg the Manhattan Dia who was elected
by the people in Manhattan
is a soros-backed animal
you understand what the context of it is
rather a grandpa Poopypants
the Cheeto dust Q anoner realizes it or
not
so please if you can spare I think it's
about an hour and a half I think it's
about 90 minutes
go watch this documentary on Netflix if
you have Netflix or if you can find it I
might even be on YouTube I don't know
again it's an older documentary
from the 1970s I believe 1973 to be
exact
and it will it will put you in a
position to know
exactly what this [__] [__] box is
trying to do now I want to give you some
confidence here because here's here's
what I believe
because I've had this discussion
personally with and I've talked about it
on the show before
is that fascism is at our front door
and really honestly it's it's it's
kicked in the door we're just holding
the door shut and they're slowly moving
it open
they used to try to break in the back
door right they used to thin veil their
fascism with conservatism
I mean they still try that a little bit
today but they don't [__] they well
they've moved well beyond that quiet
part out loud that oh it's it's
conservatism no it's not it's always
been fascism
but it's here at the front door and it's
knocking and in 1920s Germany
the difference is because there is a big
difference there is a huge difference
between now and then
and here and in in 1920s Germany our
fabric of our country is much stronger
the fabric of our country is much
greater it's much it has much more depth
to it we have the United States
Constitution protecting our country now
not to say that it's not a threat or
that it's infallible because that is
just not the truth we cannot take our
Constitution and ours fabric of our
society for granted
but the thing that we have the most the
thing that is most important here and
I've been talking to you about it the
last few days as indictment Day Has Come
day after day after day
there's a meme out there I boasted it
this morning it feels like Groundhog's
Day doesn't it
like uh well Trump indictment day again
today and we're waking up to the same
old [__]
but I I want to I want to reassure you
because you're going to be disappointed
with these
um these indictments and here's what I
mean by that he is going to be indicted
he will be arraigned which means he'll
be arrested and arraigned on the charges
they're going to let him free
okay he's gonna still be roaming around
out there talking and shelling and
screaming into a microphone and typing
messages out on true social it's gonna
piss you off
it's gonna piss a lot of people off
and he's not gonna go to a speedy trial
the whole purpose of his delay tactic
here with his campaign is to not go to
trial
Donald Trump very rarely goes to court
he almost always settles out he can't
settle out of a criminal court unless he
takes a plea deal for a prison sentence
he knows this
so he's going to use his campaign
to delay the trial
you're not going to see a trial before
2024.
at least in a criminal court
the trial that you will see for in in
is the general election and not just his
general election folks
we must start now we must start now in
the messaging and the narrative
to make sure in 2024 we position
ourselves
that we are the jury
we get to convict not just Donald Trump
but anyone and everyone who's running
who [__] supports him and capitulates
to him and harbors him
this this is most important of the trial
that will come in 2024.
we must
we must stay strong we must stay fast in
our pro-democracy Coalition
it's important
no matter what comes from the
indictments or the criminal cases
no matter what comes
it doesn't it doesn't quite matter
we are we are the backstop to democracy
not the Department of Justice
not the Manhattan D.A
It Is Us
we must remember that we are the power
we are the government It Is Us
so as the indictments start because and
it feels like they're going to be uh
dominoes right it feels like once one
happens and that's kind of the feeling
this morning is that the reason why the
Manhattan D.A is delaying the grand jury
is because someone has told them
hey Jack Smith's gonna make his move
it seems as if the crime fraud exemption
um our exclusion excuse me
is going to force Trump's lawyer to
testify
to those crimes that Trump is trying to
do through his attorney tomorrow
um all the while the same attorney is
having to go defend him today
in in a hearing and tomorrow he's going
to testify against him it's weird [__]
we're we're in a weird timeline
but it's most important that we pay
attention to these things like this
morning Alvin Bragg even though they're
delaying the Manhattan and DA's grand
jury that they convened to present the
charges to them because that's the other
thing everyone keeps calling saying
Melvin Bragg is political here he's
presenting these charges to a grand jury
now yes can grand juries be political I
guess so those individuals can have
political opinions everyone [__] does
even if they're wrong right wrong or
indifferent
but the fact remains that the grand jury
is the one who sets the indictment they
vote on the charges
but Alvin Bragg sent a warning shot to
Jim Jordan and the house Judiciary
Committee and Kevin McCarthy and and the
the America First Nazis in Our House of
Representatives hey [__] butt out of it
you ain't got no [__] jurisdiction to
come in here and [__] with my criminal
investigation good luck good luck to you
you can go [__] yourself
it's basically which is what he should
have said so what he should have said
as the House GOP is using their power
to try to weaponize the federal
government against Alvin Bragg in a
criminal investigation into the private
citizen of Donald Trump
[__] out of here with that [__]
so
stay vigilant it's okay and I understand
you're going to be disappointed here
because there's going to be a lot of
disappointments over the next year and a
half but you can't let that get in the
way of you understanding that you are
the jury
you are the jury
for our democracy
you are the jury for our democracy uh so
we're going to talk a little bit more
about his statements that he's made on
uh fraud social this morning I'm going
to show you a few other tapes but right
now there's a hearing going on
um right now in the house for uh tick
tock
and um the CEO of tick tock is uh gave
his opening statements and he's being
questioned it's not going to be an easy
day for this CEO of tick tock
and it seems like there's going to be a
lot of Crossroads that Tick Tock is
going to have to make here now the
question is is are Americans and their
data at risk here against the CCP
and the Chinese government
um and and I think I think the actual
outcome of this is that my my hope is is
that tick tock tick tock usas especially
who controls the data uh Now controls
the data of tick tock the app here in
the United States
uh comes to some sort of agreement so
this app can't be banned not that I love
the app or I want the app
um I just I just don't believe that
there is that there isn't a way to make
sure that Americans have the right to
use this app if they want if they choose
and their data can be safe I I just I I
am highly I am highly skeptical that we
can't manage this and I think it's a
broader problem right this isn't this
isn't in a vacuum just for tick tock now
the CEO this morning in his opening
statement was willing to go as far as to
say they were willing to open up their
algorithm
which is basically the proprietary
um piece of property that runs all
social media because they all have
different ones YouTube has a different
one twitch uh Facebook and Twitter Tick
Tock they all have different algorithms
it's all their proprietary code
it's what makes them tick
and talk if you wanna
throw in a pun there
but they're saying they're willing to
open that up which I think is
significant
now there is still questions around the
security and rather
they'll actually be able to
um secure the data and on the Oracle
servers in Texas which are controlled by
Americans quote American companies
again again
I believe
um there is more that we can do for
social media obviously Twitter is a
[__] hell hole it's a [__]
dumpster fire since Elon Musk has bought
it back it's it hasn't freed speech
it's it's only made it only has made bad
speech worse
which isn't a problem necessarily I mean
if you want to have a dumb idea and say
the dumb idea out loud more power to you
and really honestly if you're a person
of power and you say the dumb idea out
loud and we can see you then we know who
you are and we can toss you in the
dustpan of History like you're supposed
to right
I mean um they take take for example
um the um the Baptist Church in Kansas
what was the name of this church they
used to go out and say God hates [__]
and they used to hold gay hating signs
they were anti-lgbtq they thought the
entire world's problem was the lgbtq
community do you remember this do you
remember this this is what they would do
this is the Westboro thank you uh money
librarian Westboro Baptist Church in
Kansas
have you heard from Westboro Baptist
Church lately
hell to the no but what you have heard
is their same rhetoric
you've heard their same rent now from
people in power
this is important this is why we must
when they use their First Amendment
right we use our First Amendment right
to point it out
and I believe that is really
the ultimate
narrative around the social media
platforms
his first amendment this first amendment
that and the problem is that most people
don't understand what the First
Amendment actually is and what your
Independence or individually
individuality is of that first amendment
we want to feel like we're Sovereign in
this country each person is sovereign
we're a
fabric of our society
we're not we're not sovereign we are
individuals
and we should have freedom of Liberty
and choice
but we're not sovereign to laws and a
good example is Donald Trump the idea
that he should be above the law because
he was a president United States is
[__] stupid
that is not his Sovereign right to be
above the law he is part of our society
he is part of our our our [__]
country he has to abide by our laws it's
our government
he's an individual so yes he has all the
individual rights that someone would be
afforded but he's not sovereign from all
the rest of us and you aren't either
someone from everyone else
so we have to find a way
to manage social media going forward
because social media is in its infancy
and anyone who's scared of social media
and and oh the internet's destroying the
world and information is destroying the
world you are a bonehead the information
is not destroying the world we are just
trying to figure out how to manage
the new ability of everyone to grab any
piece of information very quickly we
didn't we this did not exist 15 20 years
ago
like it does today
it just did not exist
just like at one time TV didn't exist
video games didn't exist [__] newspapers
didn't exist
Morris Morris code didn't I mean the
list goes on and on and on here
of how we manage these things inside our
society
and I believe that there is a way that
we as a people now
I'm telling you it's going to be very
difficult until we can [__] I mean
there's people who who don't even want
people to be dressed up
in drag because they're scared
that they might they might like someone
with I don't I have no idea I just don't
know why they're trying to legislate our
fellow our fellow humans out of
existence I don't get it it's bigotry
it's fascism
it's nonsense
and that's the fight that we have to
fight because we're not going to be able
to we're not going to be able to [__]
pass decent legislation and decent
policy
around social media until we get
unserious people and out of serious
[__] positions right you're not gonna
get you're not gonna get any kind of
serious policy around social media when
you have a [__] Lauren bobert
Marjorie data green Matt gatz and Jim
Jordan and Jim Comer
who are who who who are [__] queuing
on at best it's ridiculous We're not
gonna be able to do anything with these
types of people in power
so it may take a while
to get to the point to where it may take
a couple decades folks
for us to get back in a position where
we can set good policy good policy
that that helps our citizenry and and
social media coexist in a space
but here we are here we are
I want to tell you we have a special
guest here today um he's been on before
from the radicalized podcast the Hi-Fi
is going to join us today
um him and Gabe been talking back and
forth I I guess he uh
I guess he was able to
uh hack into Trump's uh live stream or
some [__] so he's go
he's gonna tell us about that today
about how he he kind of hacked in
um not hacked they they let him in he
tricked him I think he's gonna tell us
about the day it's hilarious
um so he's gonna tell us about that
today he'll be at the top of the hour
um some people want to do
and uh shoot this [__] have we done
shoot this [__] this week moderators I
don't I don't I can't keep track did we
do shoot we haven't done shoot this [__]
this week have we let's do a little
because we've had guests every single
day this week
Emily I think we we had we had Jess
Piper on Monday Texas Paul was here on
Tuesday with Ed
uh we had we had uh Rachel bit of copper
yesterday we have high five today
tomorrow's bonehead of the week Jesus
Christ
why in the hell aren't we at three
hours why I know you folks want three
hours I know you want three hours we're
so close we're so close
um just months away from being able to
do this uh show three hours a day
but I need your help I need your help in
that effort I need you to go subscribe
to the Tony Michaels podcast YouTube
channel we're so close to 15 000 but not
only subscribe invite your friends
invite everyone you know on social media
tell them to come subscribe to this show
on YouTube also follow us on Twitter at
Tony Tony Michaels pod uh download every
single episode episode on Apple Spotify
in Google make sure to follow us on
Facebook at the Tony Michaels and also
go to the up wire YouTube channel
they've helped us out and we're
streaming over there as well so go to
upwire.com and get their Channel you can
also watch us on Twitch if you link your
Amazon Prime account you get one free
subscription over there on Twitch and
you can give us that one free
subscription another thing that you can
do to help us out to get the three hours
because all that stuff I just said was
free the YouTube channel following us
liking this sharing this sending this
link to your friends and family liking
us on all the social media platforms you
can go to the Tony michaels.com uh to
like us on all the the social media and
platforms out there but one thing you
can do
if you want to help us out with the
monetary effort here to get the three
hours because that's really the biggest
challenge is this is what me and Gabe
are trying to do for a living so we have
to I don't know pay bills you know the
lights gotta be on the internet's got to
be on the microphone's got to be powered
on
so go to patreon.com the Tony Michaels
that's patreon.com the Tony Michaels
check out my patreon page there
um I've been putting out early content
we'll probably do an ask me anything
sometime this weekend and I'll have the
Sunday rants this weekend as well so go
to patreon.com D Tony Michaels while
you're there visit Gabe's page he's
doing he's doing his skit videos again
he'll be posting them on patreon and
he's giving new episodes of what was
that and extras for what was that over
on his patreon page and so really is
what's gonna get us to three hours
I know it
you got to pay your [__] bills you
gotta eat it happens and this is our job
now this is our job we have committed
that this is our job and we want to
commit the three hours we want to do it
it's a lot of work
it seems like I just turned this thing
on and yeah you just start talking and
there's nothing else that I do it's I
gotta keep up with everything I gotta
know the [__] stories I gotta know
what's going on I got a national
narrative the messaging who's who's what
and who's where
it can get difficult it's time consuming
but I appreciate you being here every
single weekday and if you can't afford
to go to patreon no problem share with a
friend maybe they will be able to
your your support here watching sharing
liking so like the the video right now
right right now right as we speak like
the damn video that that's that's a way
to support share it retweet it if you're
on Facebook send it to a friend
copy the link on YouTube post that on
social media
those all help us in the support to get
the three hours I also want you to show
support for our moderators if you notice
we have a few new moderators in the chat
today uh Robin uh has gone to minus
touch networks Monterey everyone give
Robin a congratulations for going to the
Midas touch networks Channel as a
moderator we love we love having you
here and we love having we loved having
Robin as a moderator she's moving up in
the world she's going over to the minus
touch networks Channel which they got
almost a million subscribers and they've
got tons of shows that they do on every
single week so congratulations Robin and
welcome the mighty librarian the Deidra
today as our our new moderators that are
going to help fill the space uh where
Robin has moved up in the world so thank
you Robin congratulations and thank our
brand new moderators and welcome them
here in the chat the mighty librarian
and Deidre and give love to all the
moderators every single last one of them
it's super important you're on the best
audience in the world world one of the
reasons why is because we have the best
moderators in the entire world everyone
stick around we'll shoot this [__] when
we come right back right after this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck
I'm Paul gosar and thanks to my new
product pardon blanket I've got you
covered pardon blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup pardon blanket will
protect you too pardon blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
we're gonna shoot this [__] for a minute
we got a question for me put it down
there in the chat now I will warn you if
you're on Twitter you're typing out
questions to me I'm not gonna be able to
see that [__] I'm just telling you give
me a little bit of warning I can't see
the the comments on Twitter I I don't
know
I I have no idea
I went over this before that Twitter
used to use Periscope and it still uses
Periscope but they bought Periscope and
then made an internal tool and they
[__] it up and it was prior to Elon so
it's even worse now but then I don't
know if it'll ever be fixed so if you're
typing out [__] on the Twitter
um chat for the live feed I don't see it
like anywhere
and the only way I see it if I go watch
the show re-watch it and replay it
I just don't see it so if you're on
Twitter and here's the reason why I
posted on Twitter because I've always
posted it on Twitter
I mean to be going honest but I I
generally put the YouTube link with the
thing so you can just come over to
YouTube so just click the YouTube link
or you can click the Tony michaels.com
link it'll take you to
um the list of
uh links and I and I try to get this
show Link at the very top of the page
uh so you know which one we're on live
so you can click either those links and
that's usually what happens on Twitter
you click the link you come over to a
different chat because you can't chat
over there I don't know what I don't
know what the [__] it used to work
it used to work
and then when Twitter made
um that the Periscope part of their in
turn of tooling they they completely
[__] it up I've asked a hundred times
for them to change it if you get any
questions throw them in the chat here
um let's see if we get any questions
coming in
do you get any questions for me we're
gonna shoot the [__] do you guys know
what shoot the [__] is it's just where
we you ask me questions and I'll answer
them that's it that's it
um
uh there's a lot of questions in the
chat but you're asking each other
um some really weird questions did I
answer those I don't know I don't know
um yeah Robin's still the moderator on
Twitch he's seeing if there's any
questions over on Twitch
um and Robin thank you for filling in
over on Twitch until we find someone I
want to announce if you want to be a
twitch a moderator if you'd like to hey
throw me a message I'll I'll I'll I'll
send you to our uh our gang of
moderators and they'll they'll do the
vetting because here's the thing I I
don't actually moderate the chat the
moderators do and I give them the
ability to moderate the chat so like
when you guys see slow-mo come up I'm
doing that for them okay so when you
have slow mode it's not because I don't
like you I don't want you to comment as
fast I'm doing it for them because
they're trying to do a good job of
managing the chat and I trust them I
trust them very much with the chat I
know they're paying attention to the
chat they're trying to welcome all of
you they're trying to make the chat very
engaging for you and they do a damn good
job if you haven't noticed
and that's why I'm so I I think it's
great that Robin's going over to the
minus touch Network
I think she'll be able to take all the
things she's learned from you guys in
this chat one of the greatest engaging
chats on YouTube and she's gonna take it
over there and help them out so it's
it's very exciting so
um oh here we go uh Margie Mar Margie
Margie Margie we got Margie and Margie
there's
um on Facebook however which one you say
it and it says Tony how did you and Gabe
meet and decide to join forces where
it's really simple I've talked about
this a little bit before we met on
Twitter
I watched his videos I just sent him a
message say hey I really like your
videos you want to come on the show and
talk about how you make your videos
and he did he came on the show and then
um we joined forces because we had so
much in common we had a similar Outlook
I asked him to help with the show
because I sucked at Graphics well I
didn't suck I am not near as good as he
is just not when you when you see
Graphics put out that either me or him
did the good ones are are him the the
ones that aren't that good are probably
me
it's just just how it is
um
wouldn't uh okay this is from ba on on
YouTube be aware
or B A where b o s to go man oh man your
handle oh wink good job question
wouldn't you rather see the documents
case go forward before the Manhattan
case I don't think it matters I think a
lot of people want to make it matter
but I I mean he's gonna get indicted in
both instances here more than likely now
if Jack Smith does strike first it may
it may bang up Alvin Bragg's ability to
charge him in Manhattan who knows
who the [__] knows
I mean Alvin Bragg may take a back seat
and let the feds go with that case
a lot of times um I mean to save it
Alvin Bragg is hell-bent on Prosecuting
this case that may not be true you don't
know that Alvin Bragg said months and
months and months ago when he first took
the office that he probably wasn't going
to indict on that case
but we don't know what new evidence he
had and there may be new evidence that's
forcing Alvin Bragg to bring this case
to a grand jury he may not have a choice
whether he wants to or not whether he
wants to or not
sometimes prosecutors have to prosecute
a case that they aren't necessarily
excited about
so do I think it matters whether it's
Manhattan or Jack Smith or Georgia that
goes first absolutely not and the reason
why is because again we are the [__]
real jury here if he wasn't running for
president right if he wasn't running for
president he was just some dip [__] down
at Mar-A-Lago
who was doing really dumb [__] and kept
criming and kept going on and on and on
and he wasn't trying to save his ass by
running running in a presidential
election he's not even in a primary at
this point go show me the ballot that
the [__] has petitions for and
then I and then I'll believe he's in a
primary election he
ounce that he's just saying
I'm running for president that's the
dumbest thing I that's the dumbest
argument I've ever heard of in my life
of why you can't be indicted on crime
like again I use the example someone
robs the [__] bank the police come to
arrest him like whoa whoa whoa I just
posted a video on the internet saying
I'm running for prison you can't arrest
me it's a dumbest stupid [__] I've ever
heard of in my life
just because he says he's running for
president
doesn't mean he is in any kind of
election at all it's a really stupid
argument he will be eventually that's
what he's doing
but it doesn't stop indictments so I
don't I don't [__] think
that it matters here because we get to
[__] indict him we get to [__]
charge him we get the [__]
we're the jury we get to convict him we
get to sentence him to not being the
president of the United States so let's
remember that so the messaging is all
going to be the same uh it will be
now Linda ask when indictment
I mean that's a really good question I
think I think he thought he was going to
be arrested on Tuesday here's why I
think this a lot of people think that
he's lying but you got to remember he's
a dumb [__] right I I don't I don't
think Donald Trump was playing 40 chest
he's just a bull in the china cabinet
yelling and screaming on social media
like he's a [__] 13 year old that
just broke up with their first [__]
their first girlfriend or boyfriend okay
what happened was is Costello was going
to go in on Monday which he did
and I almost bet that his attorney said
hey this is not going to be compelling
enough for them not to indict you
and he thought his brain well if he goes
in on Monday and they come back in on
Tuesday I'm indicted which means I'm
arrested that's that's how we got to
Tuesday on last Saturday
he's just a [__] dummy he's a [__]
dummy that stopped giving him so much
credit he's an idiot he's a [__]
idiot
now when is he going to be indicted
again I don't think that really matters
either I've told you for the last three
or four months that it was going to be
Springtime what was yesterday
wasn't yesterday the first day of um
what's that season called Spring
I told you it's going to happen in the
spring so I still think that we could
certainly see indictments this month we
could certainly see indictments April
and May not and I'm not just talking
about
uh the Manhattan D.A or this obstruction
case that it seems like Jack Smith is
going to strike on
it could be the grand jury down in
Georgia and it could be super seeing
indictments that Jack Smith would bring
because that's the other thing that
people really aren't [__] saying
and well let's say Jack Smith has to
move on him like a [__] here and charge
him with obstruction because it feels
like to me and this is just my feeling
it's not my opinion because I don't have
the [__] I don't have the evidence
they're not showing us the unsealed
documents they're not showing us the
unsealed reason why the appeals court is
moving so [__] fast I mean they're
trying to push this fast there's a
reason why they're doing that I don't
believe that it's because Donald Trump
likes to delay
I I just I have a hard time believing
that the courts are scared of his delays
I think that's a bunch of [__]
courts aren't scared of someone's delay
tactics they just aren't they know it
they they they experience this
[__]
I think that there's NASA security
interest here and that is why they want
to move fast that's my feeling again my
feeling it's my it's it's it's my belief
and then it's because I don't have the
[__] unsealed documents just like you
don't just like anyone else who tells
you Trump is innocent and these charges
are all all [__] fraud and it's all
fake news and they're just trying to get
him politically and make sure he's not
the president and so it's [__] yeah
we got just as much or not as much
information as those dumb [__]
so my feeling is though that they're
moving fast for a very particular reason
and my belief is too that Jack Smith may
not even like I said Alan Bragg Alvin I
keep calling him Alan Alvin Bragg
now why I get that wrong Alvin Bragg I
get names long a lot but that one's
confusing to me Alvin Bragg
may or may not even want to prosecute
that case but he may have had a piece of
evidence that forced him to do it
just like Jack Smith may be forced to
bring an obstruction charge against
Donald Trump here and then have to do a
superseding indictment on other evidence
that he's collected because he's not
ready to indict yet on those charges
that's the thing that can happen they
can present a case to a grand jury for
an obstruction charge get the
obstruction charge from the grand jury
and indict him arraign him and then six
months a year later that same grand jury
or a different one can supersede that
original indictment and indict him on
more charges because there's been more
evidence
these are things that normal average
everyday Maga doesn't understand or
don't want to know
and the reason why is because it doesn't
fit their narrative it just doesn't
doesn't fit their narrative so I hope
that uh it helps uh we got uh look who's
late oh my gosh we're shooting a [__]
here Gabe Sanchez
um hey hang on let me bring in your your
actually he's not he's not too late he
told me he'd be here
and at about 20 till when it's quarter
till so
[Laughter]
did you finally finish that uh
to number two your day yeah I think he
was having trouble he said I might be a
while this morning I I said I said hold
the phone
um I have to drop off the kitties at the
pool there oh really they're being a
little okay reluctant to get out of bed
this morning you know what I'm saying
um okay so we're shooting this [__] here
we've got another uh we got another uh
question here and John from uh YouTube
this is a very intriguing question how
many licks does it take to get to
the titsy Roll center of a Tootsie Pop
and that's a good question John get the
[__] out of here man I think I think the
answer is like 300 and something okay uh
hold on let me
is there an actual answer yeah yeah okay
so a group of engineering students from
Purdue a group of engineering students
from Purdue University
that it's licking Machine model that for
human time whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa dude
so there is hey let me show you
something oh my God you got to see this
so this morning I posted what I post I
don't know I posted something Donald
Trump before we get too far the answer
is yeah 100 an average of 364 licks to
get to the center of a Tootsie Pop oh
okay well that makes sense but the
licking machine reminded me of this I
tweeted this this morning I got to show
you this troll you guys will like this
um it says I I said this I said feels
like if your lawyer is testifying
against you you're [__] I mean that
kind of makes sense right I mean if you
if your lawyer that's defending you in a
criminal case
um we give you know he have to testify
against you in that criminal case you
might be a little [__] this ass had
here
if you go to his page garcy's [__]
he's my guy he's posting all kinds of
great it's probably some [__] Russian
bot yeah but he says dollars to Donuts
that you're do people still use that
phrase I guess so he's dollars to know
that you're all out of personal Lube try
spit well I decided I decided to clamp
back a little bit at this sumbitch I
don't know I don't know it just felt
like it was right to me to clamp back at
him
um so I said speaking of licking machine
I don't need Lube to get your mom wet
oh I'm not scared to say it here on the
air what are you gonna do Hey listen
listen I I very rarely engage with these
Trolls but you know just sometimes
sometimes you just can't I can't help it
you know I I uh I was telling you
yesterday I I realized that
um
I I didn't post that that the Patriot
fund for that that parody commercial
that I made so I posted it to YouTube
right and you know I got a bunch of
people who are like oh this is funny and
then I got a bunch of people who are
like oh man this is this [__] man
this wasn't on Tucker Carlson this is
the this I was like all right you guys
taking this way too seriously uh and
then I had one guy who was like uh
actually if you put an actual venmo on
there or if somebody made a venmo
account after the fact uh you could be
uh it was wire fraud I was like what the
[__] are you might as well go tell every
single film and TV show that has ever
made a joke about using venmo or cash
app or whatever if people use that after
the fact or they made a fake account for
it right
uh you go go go feel like you have to go
talk to them first okay because I feel
like the attention to my video is much
less than the one over there also I
don't think I'm going to be charged with
[__] wire fraud for making a fake
venmo account if someone else may that's
on there oh my God if they don't know
what satire and parody then they are the
center and then I went to go look at the
guy's Channel and it was like all a
bunch of like oh I'm gaming I was like
dude okay whoosh whoosh so it looks like
it's the game maybe the guy who uh
wanted me to get his mom wet I don't
know that's possible I'm gonna look into
this licking machine thing though um
Ruth on Facebook says Tony how do we get
rid of Jim Jordan I'm I'm thinking
that's who you're saying yeah is Jim
Jordan and McCarthy uh vote
engaging your democracy that that's how
we get rid of those [__] I mean
we're not gonna get rid of them inside
their districts probably I mean they're
stupid people voting for stupid people
right I mean the the everyone wants
Marjorie Taylor green out of Congress I
mean you know there's something in me
there's something in me that really
wants that stupid ass to stay because
um as long as she's setting the bar for
Republicans yeah we got a really good
chance of winning because she's a dumb
book I don't know if you noticed that
but in another question the chat had to
do with um the uh the bomb threats in
New York City this week and I'm not
saying those two stories the Marjorie
Taylor green and the bomb threats are
related I mean I understand two people
were asking these questions
I think it's a good question to ask
where is she you know it's a valid
question you know some might say that
there's a app there are people saying
there are people saying there are people
saying that there's a pattern of
behavior here all right it's not me I'm
not saying that right right some people
many people online are saying that uh
the two events could be related based on
the common denominator which is Marjorie
Taylor green hmm why can't we question
if Marjorie Taylor green is the pipe
bomber does it make us an American to
question it Marjorie Taylor green wait
did you see the clip of Tucker Carlson
which one the one the one where he's
basically shot on himself no send it to
me yeah well I didn't I saw the Tweet
about about it I didn't watch it I can't
watch every [__] clip this guy This
Guy's in but I did see that he was
he was running into the wall of
themselves you know this big cell phone
I think is what it is or it seems that
way
um
well I get Michael Cohen on our show
soon I've had Michael on before
um we had Michael Cohen if you remember
um there was a meeting on a golf course
a while back and we had Michael Cohen on
and he actually debunked it Michael's
like no that's not anything that's not
yeah he was like yeah it's not anything
it's not what everyone wants to say so
this idea that Michael Cohen is some of
his credibility and he's only after
Trump and you're full of [__] because we
had Michael and you guys can go watch
that interview with Michael going yeah
go watch it I don't know what episode it
is I'd have to look it up but now people
are bringing up or like Trump's like oh
look what I found this for this this
paper
I wrote a letter yeah which is like
everyone knew that because that was
revealed in 2018. hey speaking of a clip
so we'll watch this clip of Tucker
Carlson find the clip of Rudy Giuliani
from 2018 speaking of that uh talking
about the Stormy Daniels payment that
one's oh man if you want to get a
[__] something from 2018 let's look
at that [__]
um I think uh Ron I think Ron posted it
it might be on my timeline too that
we'll we'll find it
um but uh here is uh let's see and here
is attackers clip it's about 28 seconds
you're telling me he cell phones himself
in 28 seconds no yeah surely not this
bonehead okay let's let's listen let's
hear what he says about how to Gaslight
people I think this is what he's saying
let's let's listen
Chinese it's just so easy
how do you win a war without fighting
by getting your ad for
kill himself well how do you convince a
strong self-respecting powerful country
like ours that has ruled the world for
100 years to do that turns out it's
pretty easy you take a collection of
dumb desperate people oh [__] middle age
hoping to keep on to their stupid TV you
add scripts and some hairspray and they
just repeat the lies for you and then
under here's my question here's my
question Gabe are we supposed to believe
that Tucker Carlson doesn't use
hairspray on that stupid [__] haircut
are we supposed to believe that Tucker
Carlson doesn't have the scripts written
for him by a bunch of Nazi producers are
we supposed to believe that as smart
educated intelligent Americans I don't
know what a [__] idiot are you
serious I can't say for certain but I
will assume
that I do that very thing that I'm
talking about right now all right guys
so they someone wrote that [__] out too
that's hilarious yeah because he ain't
making this up like on the Fly he ain't
improving like we do here he he wrote
and someone wrote that out like
wordsmithing it they're like ah that
really kind of sounds like us yeah maybe
we should um maybe I don't know go with
that what the [__] are you [__] I'm
trying to find this video by the way you
said it Rudy oh god damn hold on you're
late and you can't find a video yeah
usually usually he's Johnny on the spot
here uh cloudy brain this morning ah you
know hey I've got another good uh clip
of uh Bridgette Gabriel your favorite oh
I didn't I didn't you got the video yeah
this is from 2018. I did I did retweet
it this morning I couldn't remember I
did or not okay here's ears
yeah this is an exclusive interview with
Rudy Giuliani now again this is back in
2018 remember
2018. let's listen to how Rudy describes
the payment made to Stormy Daniels from
that sir having having something to do
with paying some Stormy Daniels woman
000 I mean which is going to turn out to
be perfectly legal oh so he's claiming
it's perfectly now back then she wasn't
horse face apparently right tenacious
horse face back then she wasn't let's
see if he explains yeah but remember
okay this the reason why Trump and
mainly Trump I haven't really heard
anyone else call her horse face uh other
than like his cult but the reason or or
the behavior that Trump has to be like
oh Stormy Daniels
uh she was hot enough for me to have to
pay her right to have sex with me
that I wanted it that badly right but
also uh the fact that he's now being
like Oh horse face is the typical
[__] on the playground the little kid
who gets burned by the girl who's like
look I don't like you sorry no I don't
want to be your girlfriend and then the
guy gets butt hurt right or the little
boy gets butt hurt and he's like oh no
and then and then goes to his friends
and says oh man she's such an ugly dog
and then trashes it right right that's
exactly what this is this is typical
playground type [__] and it's
exactly the the the same type of stuff
that Trump pulls all the time if someone
ever insults him embarrass him makes fun
of him whatever he then goes on the like
defensive and he's like oh no well
they're they're dumb and da da and it's
all caps and it's yelling it's non-stop
just wait I think we got a phrase for
this I think we got a phrase for this
and it [__] ass [__] ah yes there it
is [__] ass boobs well let's listen to
uh Grandpa farty mcsharty Rudy
giuliani's explanation of why this is
legal and see if you can spot where my
is having trouble right now in this
whole narrative
that money was not campaign money sorry
I'm giving you a fact now that you don't
know
it's not campaign money yeah it's like
[__] campaign Finance violation
oh really how through the law firm whoa
funnel through law firm and the
president repaid it oh oh wait oh I
didn't know he did yeah whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa Sean Hannity in 2018 was
very surprised to hear that Donald Trump
had paid back final money through a law
firm let's keep listening and let's see
what the breaking news is in 2018.
there's no campaign Finance law zero
this decision was made by everybody
everybody was nervous about this from
the very beginning I wasn't I knew how
much money Donald Trump put into that
campaign I said 130 000. he can do a
couple of checks for 130 000. what the
[__] are you [__] me I mean
it doesn't get better here like I've got
uh I still gotta I still got about 30
seconds worth of this clip and it gets
way worse it gets way worse and again
this is back in 2018. you know all the
[__] letters that Don Jr wants to
bring up none of that [__] none of that
[__] matters because Rudy Giuliani tells
on Donald Trump yo listen to this listen
it doesn't get better it gets worse I
heard uh Cohen's uh retainer of 35 000.
when he was doing no work for the
president I said that's how he's
repaying that's how he's repaying it
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
so what are you saying he's now memory
he may think he's in a private
conversation
this motherfucker's live on TV okay and
he's saying this is what he's saying
it's not a campaign Finance issue and
here's why they funneled it the word
funnel through a law firm not only that
Michael Cohen Michael Cohen wasn't
actually working for the prison and he
pays him a retainer for what obviously
it's the to reimburse him for this
payment of the Stormy Daniels uh hush
money literally he's telling you the
crime out loud and he's trying to
Gaslight you into believing that that's
not a crime keep I'm telling you it gets
worse listen listen with a little profit
and a little margin for Jesus for
Michael do you know the president didn't
know about this what wait uh I believe
that's what he didn't know about the
specifics of it yeah as far as I know
but he did know about the general
Arrangement that Michael would take care
of things like this like I take care of
things like this for my clients oh God
damn Rudy shut up dude oh my God he's
like dude you're about to incriminate
yourself on other things that you do
Shady right what people what people need
to realize so again this is 2018. yeah
yeah yesterday
I mean like you know all the clips from
2018 seem to be coming out we got uh Yo
Taco penis and you got Rudy colluder
ghouliani
uh but what what uh what people need to
realize here is that
you know there's
Trump okay so Trump issued uh 11
different reimbursement checks to Cohen
right right that's the 35 000 that I
believe chicon or his wife right right
right right right
and one signed by Trump and the other
signed by Donald Trump Jr so when Donald
Trump Jr is like well look at this form
over here just remember that Donald
Trump Jr was one of these signed
reimbursement checks okay so again when
people say like oh well it's the
organization of trump you know Trump org
not the individual here's the thing
these people know exactly what's going
on in their company so whenever you hear
someone say the organization's different
than the person no they're one and the
same especially at the Trump orc
especially in a criminal court right
when they're gonna charge them
personally for crimes they committed
with their organization right you can't
tell me that these people had no idea of
what was going on in their company that
they were committing fraud okay [__]
I want to tell you something and I know
the audience knows that I I have a
history right then I have a past that
some people have brought up online let
me reassure you a hundred percent I'll
give you a hundred percent knowledge
first hand that it does not [__]
matter if the payments were made as a
business they can indict you personally
or they can unite the business and my
belief is is this is that to actually
think because this is maga's narrative
that this that this
um indictment or this grand jury is
convened for the hush money payment
itself that is all [__] [__]
right and that is the narrative that
Rudy Giuliani is trying to take in this
explanation where he explains what crime
was committed but here's the thing why
are we to assume that crime didn't
commit be committed around this Stormy
Daniels payment while the Trump
organization was in [__] Criminal
Court where they were found guilty on 17
different fraud counts in the state of
New York why are we supposed to believe
that Donald Trump Donald Trump Jr or
anyone else related to them on the Trump
board wasn't [__] obstructing justice
during that time with this Stormy
Daniels case because they knew there was
a risk there and they weren't I don't
know maybe witness tampering or anything
else you don't know that you don't know
that yet you don't know that yet until
these charges come if they come because
some are saying that maybe Jack Smith is
going to strike first and Alan Bragg be
like well Alvin Bragg be like yeah go
ahead [__] yeah because Alvin
Bragg I don't think wants to bring this
gate I mean he may he may not he didn't
seem like he did and then maybe he got
evidence that he's like well [__] now I
gotta bring the [__] now I gotta
present my case because that's the thing
like people people right now online
especially Trump supporters like oh no
oh you there's no case here and the only
reason he brought it up was because of
George Soros and it's like yeah look
well he called him a source-backed
animal today which is I I don't know a
lot of people
um I think what it says that he's saying
in code word on true social and we'll
get to that because we're gonna have
sci-fi on here in just a minute we're
going to go to a break and have Hi-Fi
he's going to explain how he might have
got into a trump prayer meeting or
something I'm not sure exactly he's
going to explain it to us but here's the
thing is that when you call when Donald
Trump is saying in all camps ontrus true
social in his little post he calls um
Alvin Bragg the Manhattan D.A a Soros
backed animal listen you're calling him
a Jew with a hard R that's just that's
just what you're doing man that's the
code word I don't give a [__] you can
argue with me all day long all you want
about wow he's yeah he's not that's not
sorrow specs Democratic blah blah listen
you're picking out the one dude who who
donates to a ton of democratic causes
just like there's plenty of Republicans
who donate yeah plenty look at the Koch
brothers right get the [__] out like if
you if people want to play this uh but
this guy in that it's like dude you
there's there's people on both sides a
lot of money Hi-Fi will be able to give
us a whole [__] List names I'm sure
so let's do this let's go to a break
when we come back we're gonna we're
gonna figure out how he got into this
Donald Trump pray I don't know if Donald
Trump was praying or they were praying
for him or what happened I think he'll
explain it when we come back on the
other side of the break everyone stick
around we'll be right back talking about
Trump being praying or praying or some
holding Bibles upside down on the line I
have no idea we'll talk about it right
after this break
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker Conboy
there's Tammy by the time we reach DC
White was 50 strong in number some
patriots ran out of gas along the way
we have plenty of Slam jams skull
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
Circle the city again
dear Bob I'm fixing to send you some
more than Doritos you like the red bag
not the live love and blue one
in your absence I discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and I
even seen my cousin Brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
here's Tammy
[__] em [__] em [__] welcome
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
welcome back you some [__]
oh man
I can't believe I don't know if it's
like an online prayer breakfast for
Trump maybe there's plenty frame for him
maybe they're praying for him just to
get a good [__] lawyer I don't know
I mean that would be a good prayer I I
actually think he should have a good
lawyer Hi-Fi welcome back to the show
hey hey how are you my friend what's up
you son of [__] thanks for having me
yeah no problem what is this what is
this that you're gonna talk about today
you went you didn't hack into this they
let you in right or something tell us
well it's it's really interesting
because uh the person who made the
hacking possible was actually General
Michael Flynn whoa what what stop right
there are you talking about the Michael
Flynn like the traitor the killing on
her Michael Mike Flynn is Q guy yeah
that guy that guy oh okay okay so the
same wow so how did he let you in to the
uh the meeting there are the prayer what
what was it exactly what were they doing
exactly online here so what was this was
a event called pastors for the number
four or Trump they actually have a
website out there pastors for trump.com
why is it so significant the number four
is there another group that has four
spelled out or something and it's
different I don't know I'm just making
sure they're they're [__] idiots oh
okay
too far that's true okay okay
well I mean there is what is it Dimitri
or whatever they're talking about you
know so maybe it's the horsemen or some
[__] you know yeah
okay so so so what was this meaning what
were they doing what were they praying
about they were praying about the
upcoming indictments that are going to
happen to Trump and really this was just
an event there's a lot of people praying
about that by the way I mean there's a
lot of people praying people praying for
it right yes yes that doesn't happen no
I mean people praying for it they want
the hammer brought down I'm taking the
sit back and wait approach because I'm
not getting it I'm not getting
emotionally invested in all of this
you're not you're not going to do it
guys you're freaking out you're not
gonna do a prediction is what you're
saying oh eventually Donald Trump will
be revealed as the agent of foreign
Nations that he is I mean everybody's
like Russia Russia it's not he hasn't he
hasn't already been exposed to that I
thought we already went through this
you know we can talk about this actually
after the hack because I'm sure I can
draw a lot of lines for you there fine
yeah what happened here
so Donald Trump is attempting to you
know
cultivate the religious right he's also
looking to fundraise off of them and
take their money I mean he's raised what
a million and a half dollars or
something yeah uh just on his lies about
Tuesday alone and now he's trying to lie
about the the hack of his phone as well
uh General Flynn facilitated that he he
tweeted the link to his
um
General Flynn tweeted the link to his
restream.io
guest room
and I and I saw this and and and my
co-host on radicalized pod Jim
Stewardson
he's like no boomer this is your guest
link because Mike Flynn was trying to
post a link to the live stream
or the other thought is
maybe Mike Flynn intentionally sabotaged
Trump
okay you're going down really big rabbit
holes there I know but here's the thing
for that [__] I sent you to the link to
General Flynn's tweet can you pull it up
uh did you send it to me or him I said
it to him uh to his Gmail
oh yeah good luck here put it put it in
the chat here put it in the chat here on
the side all right that'll be the
easiest way in the meantime there's a
Tony if you do the go to the truth
social link so Trump actually posted
about this on Truth social what in
response okay let's look at this [__] oh
he didn't just post about it on Truth
social there were articles in the media
about it right
God damn it here's the thing look at
this [__] these [__] want to
use cookies I don't want Trump to use
any cookies you know what I mean so
here's here's his post here
um ah [__] let me back up let me get the
zoom in better here okay here we go uh
so this was yesterday he post maybe it
was the radical left are you the radical
left I I am indeed apparently okay good
the radical left maybe it was the
radical left who did it too bad the
audio wasn't working properly at the
event but it was a great honor to speak
in front of 3 000 pastors
150 15 000 people overall
some of my words were able to get
through hmm
so this was the line event where he's
talking about how you may or may not
have been the person actually we got
video evidence of it you are the
[__] that
I got video I've got video evidence I'm
going to show you
um okay so what are these the first link
you sent me here what is this okay
actually don't open the first link open
the second link because that's an
article like this this got press yeah
people were like Trump's a boomer
so this is salon.com yes Trump claims
his phone got hacked by the radical left
Hi-Fi meaning Hi-Fi uh after prayer call
goes off the rails
wow
it's a radical left okay now now click
that other link I sent you because this
is that seems suspicious when you say it
like that you know that right I know I'm
not fishing I swear I'm not gonna ask
for a password you're like you're like
I'm a I'm a Nigerian prince click that
link for me would you please like
recover your account
okay so this is uh this is uh Mike Flynn
um and um this is is this does he still
have the [__] link up
I I don't know but I didn't take a
chance so this is just an archived it
yeah oh nice yeah yeah so this is an
archive now what is this a Twitter
account is this his Twitter that's his
Twitter account okay so so this is um
this is Trader Mike Flynn's uh Twitter
account it says pray pray for America
and then it has a a restream studio link
now here I want to tell the audiences
because
um we that that is how Hi-Fi is in the
studio today is it's all [__] digital
uh people might not know this but me and
Gabe have never met in person I never
I'm much better looking than he is
that's right I just I'm a little shy I
want to spare him the embarrassment you
know what I mean now here's the thing
here's the thing is that I send out a
link uh to you guys in the audience for
YouTube for you to come watch the
broadcast I set Hi-Fi link to come into
the broadcast so he could be a guest now
Mike Flynn what he was trying to post
and you're saying maybe it's one or two
things but what what Mike Flynn was
trying to do was post where you go to
watch it not where you go to be a guest
but he accidentally or maybe
intentionally is what you're claiming I
think you're going down I think you're
going out I mean even I want to believe
conspiracy theories about these
[__] I think it's just
stupidity I think Mike Flynn's just a
[__] idiot
um excuse me for believing that but you
know I just believe he's a dumb [__] um
so but he posts the link where you get
an event so are you saying you click
that link to get into the studio that
link so you didn't actually she didn't
actually hack anything then yep so so so
they've so Donald Trump saying he was
hacked is all um uh [__] is that
what you're saying yes
yeah go ahead oh as you say it's almost
like somebody might say they were going
to be arrested on Tuesday and then
weren't going to be arrested on Tuesday
well I covered this in the first 30
minutes he knew Costello was gonna
[__] testify and they said that ain't
gonna do no good they're still going to
indict you that's what his legal theme
was telling him and he thought well
he'll do that on Monday so I'm going to
be indicted on Tuesday and that means
I'm arrested he's an idiot he's just a
[__] idiot right he's not playing 40
chest he's just a bull in the china
cabinet every once in a while looks like
he's making really cool decisions but
he's not I I will say this though what
Donald Trump has a history of is telling
lies to inflame his base and from those
lies he builds a violent power movement
right I mean these guys show up with
guns okay and the other thing he does is
he grips off of his lies look how much
money he's raising
so well right well and and maybe that's
the 40 chest he's playing but he's not
playing sports against us right I mean
come on get the [__] out of here okay so
here's obvious so here is uh you this is
you took a screenshot here and this is
you ready to join join the stream now
this is you joining as a guest right
because it wants you to have your
microphone and your camera and it says
holy [__] so you are surprised by this
yep and actually if you look right above
that replying to Jim Stewardson
um Jim
pointed out that Mike did this right
yeah
um and then and then uh down here below
you have another
uh I just I just all I did was hit yeah
and and that accepted you in yep so who
was in charge of this of this broadcast
well technically that would be the
pastor
uh Jackson whatever
and here is here is the pastors for
trump.com please audience don't
whatever you do whatever you do do not
don't do what I think you're gonna do
okay just refrain from being [__]
maybe this week maybe next week go [__]
with them a little bit at pastors well
there's nothing really there's nothing
really there anymore oh so that's a
matter of fact it's not an email or
anything I'm just you know I'm just
snowballing here
um I well there could be you know emails
you could send or something like that
actually Trump has a rally coming up
that you can sign up for tickets online
no we don't want you to do that and here
we you definitely do not go sign up for
10 000 tickets don't do that that would
be the wrong awful that would be the
wrong thing to do which by the way yeah
I was gonna say his Waco 30-year
anniversary rallies it's
obvious or not get the [__] out of here
and these guys okay so here uh Ron uh
Philip Kowski you sent this um
this is the pastor claiming that the
trolls hacked in
okay so let's listen to this real quick
it was incredible but here's where the
problem came
through the platform we were streaming
through yeah there's a backstage for the
speakers right well that link somehow
got out
I wonder I wonder I wonder he tweeted it
so wait wait wait here's what happened I
now I now I now I'm on to it I get it
this this buffoon who is on uh Mike
lindell's uh Qtv here or whatever the
hell it's called my fellow Nazis TV
um this guy this guy set up the stream
and he sent he sent the studio link for
Mike Flynn to join
and Mike Flynn's like oh this is the
link that I'm supposed to tweet out so
he tweeted that link out and you just
click that [__] and they're like
who is this Hi-Fi guy in the green room
because folks I I this I don't know if
you know this I actually even high five
I don't have to let him in the broadcast
let me show you let me demonstrate real
quick see there he's out he can't come
in he can't say anything he can't do
anything he's just hanging out now he's
back okay see it's like magic I just
click the button and it's internet
digital left-wing radical socialist
commie Bolshevik magic Donald Trump used
the word Bolshevik the other day by the
way but let me finish let me finish this
clip I want his explanation I want to
hear his side of the story here
of why he's an idiot let's let's listen
trolls infiltrated the backstage
literally kicked us out of our own uh
broadcast oh now wait a second wait here
you didn't kick him out though did you
no I mean I control this broadcast Gabe
controls this broadcast Hi-Fi all's
Hi-Fi can do is sit here and wait for me
to pull him in and out watch I'll show
you again another demonstration see
there he's gone now he's back derry's
gone now he's back here Tony I know no
you're the sticker you're in the troll
this is some deep deep deep
State it's technical [__] when you just
click the button it's it's really hard
stuff I'm not saying I'm not saying it's
easy to do a broadcast like I do uh but
the software I have is very similar to
the one they're using we use stream yard
to be completely oh completely
transparent it's not hard damn it
someone's gonna hack us it's not hard to
know it's not it's not hard to know
because you can tell that's what we're
using right uh it's it's a and restream
typically has a you can tell they're
using it especially when you send the
[__] link out to get into the room
okay let's let's maybe he's got a better
explanation here I doubt it but once
once listen
on our end we've got kicked out froze
out removed and that's where uh we went
offline and so it was an incredible
thing to have a hundred and fifteen
thousand people joined live to the
president Trump uh unfortunately the
trolls like I said they got into the
back end and uh you know they do what
they do they bring about uh disharmony
and destruction uh it sounds like I will
admit to that it probably sounds like
what you did is embarrass the holy [__]
out of them
you embarrassed the holy [__] out of
them and they shut their broadcast down
because they were terrified that somehow
you had hacked in it's always funny to
hear these people be like oh man this
canceled culture woke uh group of people
who these antifa they're always trying
to cause chaos and violence and I'm like
yet you guys are the same ones who
smeared your own [__] on the walls of
the Capitol okay so let's not even try
to compare the two right now well Paul
makes a good point here on YouTube Paul
says [__] around find out like I mean
yeah you [__] around and have you send a
link to Mike Flynn and tell him to tweet
the link and he tweets that link people
are probably gonna click that
[__] I mean he's tweeting a link
for you to pray pray there's gonna be a
few people clicking that link I don't
know maybe it's just me you know the
funny part is though if you would think
that you wouldn't have been the only
[__] in the room or the only
person requesting if Michael Flynn
tweeted that link right or am I [__]
wrong what well I mean let's let's watch
the video I sent you and you can see how
many people are in the waiting room with
me which which which one is that are you
getting on uh is that uh I sent it I
sent you a shared movie file oh God damn
yours oh my God you suck just okay send
me the Tweet where you got the video
before we play the video there was a
there's a signal noise that's playing in
the video
is that from your end or their end so
I've talked to some audio experts about
it and I've got Jesus Christ I fight you
talk to audio experts yeah the [__] out
of here come on man dude I know people
who have been in audio and audio systems
and cabling and speakers and I'm like
what okay what did this what did the
experts say
uh a couple guys said it sounds like
it's an active audio countermeasure to
prevent recording
because when I was taking the video I
heard nothing
right I didn't hear the beep until I
played the recording wait wait wait wait
wait I I want to be sure I'm clear on
what you're saying so when you were on
the broadcast and you were doing because
you were recording send me that some of
that tweet that you sent that that you
tweeted that out on um you're you're
using a camera to record you on this
you're not screen recording it right
it's not a screen grab you're just so
what you're saying is possibly the
microphone of your other camera picked
up a high frequency sound that you
couldn't hear only the microphone on the
phone here is that what you're saying
yes now okay to be fair the some of the
other audio experts I talked to said it
sounds like feedback which is also
possible given how close the phones were
to each other right so Oh you mean you
mean either you mean feedback in the
recording from from one phone to from
one from one speaker and then into the
microphone in the other like like if you
get a microphone too close to a speaker
or a sound set it gives that high
frequency is that what you're saying yes
okay and and that is one thing I was
told it could be that also so if you
listen to Trump's audio
he cuts off like right at the same time
uh
let me find you the Tweet you guys
um
hold on a second sorry I'm scrolling
through my uh you got way too many you
tweet too much you know man
a lot of it I actually do automated oh
and Jesus Christ this guy okay I'm gonna
go to Media I'll find it it's I think I
[__] sent it to this uh over the
weekend here I'll put it in the chat
I'll put it in your DMs on Twitter no no
just put it here damn you
sorry I don't mean to be so demanding
but it's so much easier for me to all
right
chat I'll send it to me yeah
this is this is this is
this some kind of security measure where
you don't want oh here it is wait no is
that it no that's that's a Kelly surreal
video when's is that from that's oh 21st
oh Lisa Ray uh so she was an oath keeper
no it's so real because she's so real so
real
she is right whatever she is she tried
to file a uh Supreme Court Document she
had a supreme court filing that had the
anonymous mask on it and at that time I
still kind of I got it I found it yeah
go ahead go ahead go ahead anyway I felt
I had mixed feelings about Anonymous
um now I know that Anonymous has been
infiltrated by Russia and Peter Thiel so
I'm not even messing with them but I
trolled Kelly and I made her change the
filing and when she filed it the next
day it was changed
okay so here's the video I got it here's
a video of me in the backstage so you're
you're in a backstage here you can see
Trump is speaking at this point yes so
you're so you're not actually is your
microphone on at this point it doesn't
you can hear me on the recording but I
don't think you can hear me on live
stream unless you're hearing like
everything and Trump was dialed in so I
don't know what kind of conferencing
capabilities that restream.io has well I
mean it's the same here so like um like
here I'll show you I can shut your uh
let me see
ah no you can shut your camera off and
just be an icon like he is here in and
same in the Stream yard I'm sure it's
same and restream well here let me show
you yep see that just like that and they
would put a right so there's an example
of it so he he's and the reason why is
because he he doesn't have his drag cast
his Trump drag costume on yet right so
he's not on camera for the what what are
you laughing at no he's not on camera I
I don't I know I I know the reason why I
know the reason why I mean I'm supposing
but the reason why he's not is because
he didn't have his his drag costume on
he's got he dresses up in Trump drag you
know that right
well yeah I know he wears me yeah yeah
right the makeup he does his hair he he
gets in that girdled suit of his the
oversized suit he wears the heels what
are you laughing at I'm being
seriously I'm having to go through all
of that and yet the GOP is so terribly
afraid I know well they are let's let's
watch the video here of how you um may
or may not have hacked in and sabotage
their great prayer of the of the mango
Mussolini Jesus the radical left wing
has destroyed our prayer let's watch
thank you very much oh my God
thank you
very much
so when you start talking they stop
talking it seems yeah yeah just like
what they're like whoa wait a second is
there is there someone is there someone
in the in the Stream with us uh what's
funny is in the lead up to you saying
that he's like the crazy people the
crazy people and here here you are the
crazy person I'm just hanging out
backstage man right well let's let's
hear let's listen because uh you'll hear
the sound here in a few seconds that
we're talking about earlier like the
feedback or maybe it's some sort of
thing that they did I think you're I
think your your audio expert said his
feedback is correct but let's listen
let's see if I can get on camera
that's that's the sound so there's the
sound
um of the of the feedback it seems I'll
say this it seems a little weird that
there's such a delay from when he
started recording to even got the phone
closer and there was no feedback and
then all of a sudden it started randomly
during yeah but that may be because
someone didn't have their mic open and
they're trying to open mics and close
mics because they don't know they don't
know who has mics open and who doesn't
and they're trying there may have been
several people in the room and they're
trying to figure out because sometimes
like um for example when Dr Rachel
bidikoffer comes on she's using the
microphone on her phone in the video and
people don't know this but I have to
mute her when she's not talking because
there's an echo or a loop of where her
microphone on her phone is picking us up
talking so I've got to manage that in
the room
um and some other guests too now now
Hi-Fi has his earbuds in so he can hear
us talking in his ears but his
microphone can't hear me so and and even
like my volume on videos I sometimes got
to turn the volume down on my videos
because it's really loud in my ears so
you guys can hear but I'm so close that
even my covered headphones sometimes my
mic picks it up so that's that's
probably what happened is when you got
in the room the people who were
producing in a running the room are like
whoa whose [__] mic is open and
they're trying to close mics and open
mics and they just so happen to have one
open
at the time that you pulled that phone
close and that's probably where that
feedback loop came in
um that would be my guess I don't think
it's uh conspiracy I'm wrong here's the
thing if you listen to the actual live
stream which I would like to point out
the pastors for Trump
YouTube site pulled down the live stream
edited in a interview that they had done
with Trump separate from the live stream
so they got rid of all that mess and
noise right the only people who will
know about it are the people who saw it
right and the people who read about it
so in other words so in other words they
edited out of existence that way he
could say it's the radical left hacking
into the broadcast I mean that's the you
know Trump MO
I mean well they they unlisted the live
stream but I captured the live stream
link and put it in that thread so you
can still hear it I just deleted the
video which they may eventually uh
Delete or make it completely private to
where you can't actually you have to be
logged into their account to see it so
Hi-Fi I appreciate it I know we were
going to talk about something else but
man I got some videos I got to show the
audience here come back and tell us what
was what was the thing you were going to
talk about
um on the other side of this I don't
know we we got a mock Trump for and
Michael Flynn but what was the thing you
wanted to talk about well the reason why
I say it is possible that General Flynn
is uh oh yes intentionally sabotaging
Donald Trump
is because Michael Flynn has Network
ties
back to the October surprise with Jimmy
Carter Iran Contra
and even back to Nixon and Watergate so
why don't we talk about rabbit holes and
conspiracies for you well if you if you
guys want to go see conspiracy theories
at its best go follow Hi-Fi uh on
Twitter he's doing these whiteboard
things I always enjoy having you my
friend even even if even if maybe I
think you're in rabbit holes that I I
don't I don't agree with maybe I am hey
I don't know I don't know I think it's
fun though you know what here's the
thing here's the thing is that um we
always give the right wing [__] about
their conspiracy theories
but it works it works and and narrative
and messaging folks and we got to win
elections here so you know what if um if
if we're just like asking questions like
Tucker Carlson's asking questions we can
do right what are you gonna do what are
you gonna do I have I have two things to
say yeah to refute that and the first is
yes it may be conspiracy theories
but all of mine are backed up with facts
and two
if we're wrong right why is there a
concerted troll effort
to undermine us well let me let me three
years now let me ask you something
because this is the question that I
think would set you guys apart
um from anyone else if you're proven to
be wrong you'll admit that you're wrong
correct absolutely and as a matter of
fact we were proven wrong recently yeah
we we thought that microchip was a
fellow named Justin mcconey turns out
microchip is not Justin McConaughey I
will admit to that openly apparently
microchip is some neckbeard with greasy
brown hair who wears hoodies okay I
don't know anything about this microchip
game but what I'm saying is is that I
believe you Jim uh the the people over
at rantic lines podcast would admit when
you're wrong if you're proven wrong and
that I think is the difference right
because right the difference is they're
based in reality
and anyone on the right is not well what
is reality what is real well you know uh
I think it's pretty objective what
reality is right now and one group is
unwilling to accept the facts of the
surrounding environment and it's in its
uh here's the fact here's the fact uh
Mike Flynn sent out that link because
he's an idiot and uh you clicked into it
and they let you on the show and they're
idiots and they were proven to be it and
then they tried to lie about it so
there's your conspiracy theory Hi-Fi
come back and see us my friend uh come
back soon and see us give us some more
of your uh Rabbit Hole conspiracy
theories I always enjoy them everyone
stick around we're gonna watch some
video of protesters in New York I'm not
[__] you they're there these [__]
Trump supporters want to [__] Brandon
I'm serious stick around I'll show it to
you the evidence the facts when we come
back right after this
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment where
back to the Tony Michaels podcast
I thought it was appropriate to play the
commercial that Gabe was talking about
earlier about the wire brush
[Music]
just a bunch of right-wing idiots who
are super pissed off that they can't
take a joke holy moly and that they are
the butt of the joke and they are the
they aren't they aren't um well we want
to stay on video yesterday was it
yesterday or day before in fact I know
yesterday yesterday uh a really horny
guy a really horny guy in New York City
I mean he had some some horns he was
horny oh this man he was running yeah
there's another video this horny guy
wanting to [__] Brandon apparently yes
um I I didn't I swear I did not know
this when we were playing that video and
I said something about Walter Masterson
yeah yeah well I said I was like there's
no way this is real I mean because the
way that this is I said I said it's kind
of like when Walter
does this thing well there's another
video of uh some people protesting some
Trump supporters protesting outside the
Manhattan Court here it is
um here's your first look on me Tony
Michaels podcast it's it's only a few
seconds long but boy they seemed all
riled up here they seemed horny to [__]
somebody let's let's listen we are here
in front of the courthouse where they're
gonna legally your arrest Donald Trump
we are here
to [__] Brandy
we're gonna [__] Brandon today
[Music]
let's [__] him
even the cameraman couldn't hold their
laughter
[Laughter]
oh my God okay it's funny it's because
you hear it all the time right and you
hear it like sincerely genuinely from
Trump supporters like oh man Joe Biden
Brandon he can suck my dick and it's
like whoa whoa why do you why do you
wanna why would you want him to do that
dude like really aren't you the one
who's like Macho you don't like gay
people kind of [__] why are you telling
that you want another man to perform a
sexual act on your penis speaking of
that I've got another video of now that
was just a small protest I've got a
video of a much bigger protest oh yeah
at an in and out burger I don't know why
and then that burger but I got a video
of this it's evidence I got it I'll show
it to you oh the one out here in
California yeah yeah I got that video
too I'll show that to you but uh first
off I want to show you I found this
and it really triggered a lot of it
really triggered a lot of the the people
that you're talking about it triggered
them it says some conservative watching
drag videos and then down here at the
bottom it uh I don't know is this uh is
this something she's either watching
videos and then this is the result
I feel something and I'm so mad that
this makes me feel weird I don't know if
I swear I think it's where I swear I
swear if Republicans and right-wing and
[__] nuts if they would just accept
the feelings they have like inside
themselves and be like oh my God whoa
whoa makes me happy and they were to
pursue said happiness I don't know man
that sounds you you give you give a
license to a bunch of people who have
rapey thoughts okay all right well okay
well I mean you know right okay let's
clear that up but what I am saying is
that the hatred that these people have
because we know based on studies and
facts that a lot of uh homophobia is is
rooted in your own desire uh what it
reminds me oh someone was posting the
other day that grinder is threatening to
release and I don't know this is true or
not the grinder is threatening to
release data from Florida politicians oh
I hope they do in Florida they if they
don't stop [__] passing anti-gain
anti-trans laws they're gonna they're
gonna release they're like woof we'll
[__] dock you [__] we will [__]
dox you if you I mean I look sucks I
don't know I don't know if that's true
it's great whatever you're sucking or
whatever right whoever the point is as
long as it's consensual yeah and it's
legal whatever whatever you want to do
look right it's no it's not a big deal
it's human nature right people like men
people like women women like men women
like women it's all whatever dude it's
all over the place you be you you should
just be lucky that you're able to just
live this life in existence in a time
that is obviously you know debatably
obviously much better than it was
previously but some people want to take
that away from others
and it's just like at the end of the day
I really think that if these people
these crazy people were able to be like
oh dude I'm gay I like men or like or I
I'm [__] pansexual or whatever it is
right that they would be so much happier
and that they would have so much less
hate oh I've got a I got a video for you
for that one okay all right but but
first I gotta go to this another Trump
rally that happened it was huge oh my
God there's
there's um I don't know tens maybe ten I
think they they got like half a dozen
and people yeah
um so this is well I'll just play the
video it's in an in and out burger in
Laguna Hills California let's listen we
are here in Laguna Hills California at a
random in and out parking lot where I
guess Donald Trump's most loyal uh
supporters there are tens of them have
gathered to protest his impending
indictment okay so the report is here
that there's tens obviously this is the
good liars video how do they [__]
find I mean did they get like they're
like sure they're in some I'm sure a lot
of this conversation has happened like
in telegram groups or they're like
they're monitoring this yeah I think I
think they're in groups that are like
also probably on Facebook 100 people are
like oh Justice for Trump and liberty
for Trump and freedom for Trump pastors
for Trump right that's whatever whatever
you fill in the blank for Trump and I'm
sure in one of these forums somebody's
like yeah we shot it we gotta go here or
sit up man we get up and tailgating [__]
with the [__] few times when they
pick out pick the in and out braids
because they want to have food close by
well I do want because in and out is
Christian right it's a Christian owned
restaurant yeah man it's Christian oh
okay okay is there like does they have
like the crucifix and the cross no no no
they have I think they've on the on the
bottom of the cup they've got a a
passage like reference
but that's it I haven't I haven't seen
it I mean I've gone to in now before so
you're so wait you're telling me so you
haven't gone because of that no no no
I'm saying I have gone I'm saying to
this one specifically no no I've never
been to Laguna Hills one no okay
well it just feels weird that they would
show up I mean it's totally weird I
would feel like that Donald Trump's cult
would go to a McDonald's to be quite
right I mean you would think McDonald's
or Walmart like that I I really found
this weird that they were in and out and
not McDonald's yeah or a chaos I mean or
KFC and then out you know like they came
in I guess for a minute and then
now it seems like when we watch this
video it seems like it's kind of like in
a shopping mall so maybe that's why they
picked it too because like McDonald's
wouldn't let him protest our our rally
I'll look it up while you're talking
yeah sure while I'm talking I'm always
talking yeah okay let's well let's play
the video let's let them talk because he
interviews some interesting characters
here probably the the ones they were
following on like telegram or something
um they're like oh there's gonna be some
crazies at this one that we can talk to
Let's listen
how many people do you think are here I
don't know maybe 50 on and off okay yeah
it looks like yeah maybe 20 maybe
so she's like so so he's
people which is 20 because dozens would
be at least 20 tens of people right like
20. well and then she's like oh there's
got to be at least 50. like if you're
counting the people who aren't
protesting and wearing Trump [__] in the
parking lot there might be right there
might be 50. yeah you mean depending on
what kind of radius you're including
here like across I mean if you run a
month right sure you know it'll it'll uh
it'll get there I just love her costume
though right
um
man I don't know you know these people
lost their minds when uh Colin
Kaepernick you're dishonoring the flag
like yeah cut it up and you made it into
an outfit lady like what I mean I'm not
against it I think I think we should be
able to [__] burn the flag tear the
flag [__] on the flag and tell it to go
[__] itself yeah I mean that should be
our Liberty you you
you should be able to I mean people do
right obviously whatever they want but
also it's like if you were a true
constitutionalists you would know that
you can't do that you would know that
you're not supposed to actually have
merchandise and other materials that
have the flag on it because it's
desecrating the flag but these people
also these people [__] let that flag
touch the ground all the time which
you're not supposed to do right so these
people were like oh I'm a patriot man
[__] I love the flag and the
Constitution
dude you guys are wearing [__] thongs
that are made out of the American flag
tell me the founding fathers you think
this lady has an American flag thong on
I guarantee well I don't know maybe
maybe bigger like bigger Point like
bigger kind of Granny pants granny panty
type yeah patriotic thing but I wasn't
surprised one of the dudes driving that
big Ram [__] 150 over there or
whatever
tiny weenie
little little mankini I think they
interviewed that guy in this video so
let's watch and the reason why this is
important and relevant because I'm gonna
show you I'm gonna show you a a a post
today that Grandpa poopy pants he wants
these people I'll show you I'll show you
why this is relevant but let's watch the
other interviews pretty good for rain I
think if he truly did something illegal
yeah it would be better right but why
would it be bad his lawyer gave her some
money to not say anything so that he
could uh win the election
yeah
for congress I got 2 192 votes 1.2
percent of the vote and one of the way
s sorry
I think this greatest I think that's the
guy with the truck I mean it might be
the guy okay before no before we play
this crazy guy I just want to point out
when you you got to remember that when
people
numbers like down to the down to the
fraction matter to some of these people
right he goes I got 1.2 percent in the
vote you know 1.256 this is the same
thing who's probably like I mean it's
like
4.78 inches like it's down to the
[__] decimal that they they have to
know the size or they have to know the
number because you're like I got I got
about one percent or I got over one
percent but the fact he's like I got 1.2
percent numbers [__] matter to these
people to the to the extent that they
don't understand that it's more
embarrassing for them to know the
specifics you know people are pointing
out this shirt Rhino Hunter yeah it's
well you know you know what's funny
about like the last video we saw of
Walter which is is parody and satire
they're making fun of these people now
you understand why people would confuse
them for real yeah I mean look look at
this guy look at this [__] guy
the orange shirt like
yourself come on well here's the next
the next guy is the same [__] way
let's listen oh this guy's crazy I think
they sprayed us with vaccine components
in January do what January 7th I was all
inflamed and I couldn't use my fingers
yeah you should know that he has at
least these these 20 people standing
with them there are so many of us that
know what you did peace in the Middle
East y'all jumped in peace in the Middle
East yeah
didn't you see that it was also really
cold is it possible that that's why
you're I think the really cold was the
Frozen Spike proteins that they were
releasing in the vaccine it was cold the
weather was cold because of the vaccine
yes I think it was literally drone
delivered uh vaccine components and
that's what whoa whoa okay folks this
guy votes okay yeah this guy definitely
goes and he votes every single time and
here's it I don't know if he's from
California and he's voting I mean
there's a lot of conservatives you know
Republicans that live in California I
don't know
would you call him conservative Republic
are just crazy yeah no I mean like sure
I'm look I'm grouping them until until
that party is able to split off and say
look we're not crazy anymore and we
actually care about these fundamental
ideas like the I'm gonna call them all
the same thing right Republican party
you're [__] Maga conservatives you're
[__] Maga your crazy extremists who
stormed the captain yeah but he just
said that the the Frozen Spike protein
vaccine made the weather cold
it was it was it was um what's the month
that that the Insurrection was in what
month was it uh
uh you mean the one that starts with the
J yeah January that's yeah I mean
there's June July but January next one
what what season is January in
well you know typically it's winter
right like wait wait wait now wait now
wait now wait no way State of Mind wait
I remember in kindergarten we had this
little book and it had the four seasons
in it
Four Seasons Landscaping no no no no no
no the Four Seasons
in in his winter oh oh oh oh oh okay
bring autumn
and how how can't they know that it's
cold in January in Washington DC do they
not know this it's I don't know man it
[__] it's all right I mean I would I
would like really honestly if the guy
was like look it was July it was the
July 6 Insurrection right if it was the
July 6th and it was like 32 degrees and
snowing and okay I'd be inclined to you
know start listening to your your Frozen
Spike protein things but really are you
[__] kidding me I mean also look it
also might be hard because maybe he was
like beating someone up or or I don't
know maybe like yeah do you actually
think that guy was at January 6th or
he's just [__] crazy
I don't think I don't I I don't believe
it's really kind of hard if you're
believing if you're believing this guy
anything he said like when he starts at
like the vaccine made the weather cold
like it's hard to believe anything this
is yeah but at the same time I'm also
like that's exactly the demographic of
people who would have shown up on
January 6th that's true I'm the same guy
who would have just smeared his [__] on
the capitol right right you know like
take that protein spikes colders
like the idea that he's like they were
able to track us because they hit us
with those vaccine [__] sprays Spike
proteins they hit him we went through
the mega Domino
yeah that's how they would say it is it
does that have to do with meganomics
yeah is it just a magnetometer no no
it's a magnetometer oh magnometer what
is the magnetonomer what is that that's
something else man oh okay okay
is what they call the metal detector
they're like man I'm going through the
mega nominal and I got sprayed in the
face with this macro team man it's so
easy it's so easy you want to know what
he got sprayed with in the face [__]
bear mix he got [__] spray in the
face with bear mace that is what he's
like oh my my mom my hands were so low
my muscles are so it's because you got
[__] beat up or you were beating
someone up and the adrenaline is running
and the following day
you were [__] tight and also in it
was in the cold right right damn man you
guys are so [__] dumb but amazing
because well I just love it this is the
reason why I played this because it's so
important to understand with the next
thing I'm gonna show you which this
morning uh the Cheeto does q anoner not
only did he post a video of John Voight
uh having oh yeah yeah that's weird but
anyways he posts this and he's begging
his shirt Army to come save him with
violence literally this is what he's
doing and that's not the only one he had
another one right I'm gonna show that
one too but this one here this is the
reason why I showed you the video I just
showed you because
I I just want to show you the evidence
of what is happening and then what he's
trying to get people to do everybody
knows I'm one other well I hear
Let me let me clear my voice because I
gotta read this properly everybody knows
I'm 100 innocent he's literally
screaming I I don't know how else to do
this is how an innocent person right uh
declares their innocence 100 including
brag but he doesn't care he is just
carrying out the plans of the radical
left lunatics I wonder if it's the same
radical left that hacked into his uh
prayer thing okay maybe he goes on to
yell our country is being destroyed
as they tell us to be peaceful
explanation he forgot the wink he forgot
the wink so what he's saying here is hey
they're trying to tell us to be peaceful
but they're destroying our country so we
need to you need to seek retribution on
me for 100 innocence now here's why this
is important
of those people
that you saw in that video that I just
showed that the good liars were standing
outside some random Rando in and out
burger or a bunch of randos like I don't
know eight or ten of them showed up are
you scared if those people start rioting
are we are we gonna be I mean those are
the type of people that that
accidentally trip on the ground and then
stab themselves with the spear they made
out of their American flag right right
which is what we saw on January 6th
there was a literally one of the people
that uh
that uh representative Loudermilk gave a
two or two okay the following day after
his January 5th Tour on January 6th he
showed a video of him of himself again
everyone recorded themselves in this
[__] idiots
but they recorded themselves and in this
video he was like oh man I made his he
like looked at the American flag and
sharpened the end into a spear so when I
see these people who are like I'm going
to Laguna Hills California at an in and
out burger parking lot to [__]
protest the fact yeah Donald Trump is
going to be indicted and arrested that's
going to help these people are not the
cream of the crop but these people are
definitely the people that would trip on
their way out of the [__] shower
on their way to the Laguna Hills in and
out parking lot this was the best
comment and then [__] die this was
the best comment underneath that post
fire up the scooters
oh my God I mean this is why on Monday
the Republicans all at once came out and
said hey don't protest don't do it
don't want to protest and the reason why
is because they knew this In and Out
Burger situation where the good liars
would go and make fun of these people
and there'd be videos all over the
Internet embarrassing the [__] out of
trump they knew that was gonna happen
and he's still calling for violence
today because he didn't get the violence
he wanted this week so he's calling for
it today but not only that he is
literally calling well not literally but
I think it is it's pretty goddamn close
he's calling Alvin Bragg a Jew with a
hard r i mean come on let's just let's
just call it what it is so he's yelling
in this one again he he can't get the
caps lock off his phone
I don't know if he knows how to use the
camp Locker do you think he's
tippy-tappy typing on his computer or
he's Tippy tapping typing with his
thumbs oh it's he definitely does not
use a computer yeah he's definitely
using I think he's like do you think
he's like a like a little like
like a bird pecker like no I I think I
definitely think this is while he's
[__] oh okay this is definitely wild
I mean it could be one of those [__]
rants now I'm not saying on the toilet
anymore he didn't really [__] on the
toilet he's probably sitting in his in
his Lazy Boy and he's you know he's
taking a big dump in his diaper and he's
getting pissed off and he puts the caps
lock on I don't think he's got it you
know accidentally locked up here I think
he literally is yelling it's it's do you
think he's yelling at the clouds do you
think he's doing voice to speech but
he's like all caps
so are you saying voice to speech knows
when you're yelling so they just do okay
I wonder I wonder I do I've never really
tried it I've I've spoken to my phone in
a casual polite right calm manner before
okay so I have no idea what it's like if
I were to try you know what here I'll
I'll put myself on mute yeah see if you
can try it okay so I'm gonna read the
message why Gabe is testing that out
here we go it I it doesn't make a lot of
sense I apologize but here it goes why
won't Bragg drop the case question mark
everybody says there is no crime here I
did nothing wrong exclamation point it
was all made up by a convicted nut job
with zero credibility who has been
disputed by highly respect professionals
blah blah blah black refuses to stop
blah blah blah he meaning Bragg is a
soros-backed animal who just doesn't
care about the right or wrong no matter
how many people are hurt
this is no legal system this is the
gazpacho he spelled it
it's Macho spelled it wrong yeah right
this is Russia and China but worse
disgraceful now again he invokes the
Nazis and then he calls he calls Alvin
Bragg who's a black man and I don't
think Alvin Bragg is Jewish is he I
don't think he is I don't know is he
Alvin bragacy Jewish I don't know yeah I
don't know I mean he could be I mean
what's stopping him from being Jewish
but I don't I don't think he is but when
you say he's Soros backed animal and
again I want you to go on animals right
well see a lot of people I well a lot of
people said it's because he's black that
they said yeah yeah that's where I'm I
don't I don't think that's what he's
saying oh you don't if you go back I
told the audience here about a
documentary on Netflix called Hitler a
career and you go back and you listen to
his language he would call Jews animals
they're animals and I think that's when
he says Sorrows backed animal now
obviously Alvin Bragg is black and his
his Nazi supporters know that Alvin
Bragg is black so they already have in
their minds to use the hard R when they
describe Alvin Bragg but maybe a Jewish
heart art would be um better for him to
perpetuate here and he's doing that when
he says Soros back then I think he's
calling him a Jew is what he's calling
him yeah yeah I mean he's not but I mean
like I said like brag is not Jewish but
right but I could see him pushing that
obviously that idea I I do well oh I
mean I could see him pushing the idea
like animal is uh
uh animal is is for Jewish but I also
think that like the black I think it is
more of him being a black person and
pushing that idea I mean like we know
that Trump is [__] racist Also if
anyone was curious because I know you
guys are and you're you're a fan and
follower of science I did just test out
the uh talk to text feature on the
iPhone and regardless of how loud you
yell because I tried to lie I I yelled
pretty loud all right
um it it just converts it into normal oh
okay so it's basically the phone is like
yo chill out man I'm gonna [__] lower
the volume for you right here so
literally it doesn't seem like you're
because you're [__] crazy so
literally he would have to put caps
locks on to do this or yeah is he is he
capitalizing pushing the letter
capitalizing pushing the letter oh I
mean like unless he had I mean no I
don't think he's like he's like for
those for those who had a you know flip
phone back in day when he had T9 and you
had to be like all caps and you're like
one two two one two one two two I don't
think he's going one by one I think he's
all caps and he just went [__] at it
and he was like
and he's like you're not gonna stop me
brag ah meanwhile Brad sitting by and
he's like yeah I mean just keep doing
that I guess uh you can keep yelling and
bitching and moaning all you want but
it's not going to change the fact that
we have a grand jury that most likely is
going to indict you and you're going to
have to come in we're gonna take your
[__] mug shot we're gonna we're gonna
fingerprint you we're gonna do the whole
[__] King caboodle baby
and you can't avoid it I promised you a
um a video of an incel Nazi yeah I know
what you're gonna play [__] this guy
um
I I don't I I mean this really doesn't
have anything to do with anything
besides this guy's got a big following
and I really think that his following is
probably
um more dangerous as far as like people
that could be incited to I mean some
sort of violence this person I mean I'll
just say who it is Nick Fuentes right
Nick Fuentes was at the Capitol on
January 6th and he told through a
[__] megaphone a bullhorn to his
followers he was like oh we got word
that we got on the Capitol and he was
like attack them attack them you go in
make sure they know that it's ours right
hours right this guy is [__]
dangerous right so listen to what he
says here about women and see if you can
spot
um
well let's just play it Jesus Christ
let's just play it I I'm not surprised
okay
says the guy
says the guy who was
completely sensitive and irrational this
guy
is so emotional
I want to remind you I want to remind
you emotional Gabe I want to remind you
that this guy not only is he emotional
but he had dinner with Donald Trump yeah
if anyone's um Donald Trump was taken he
was taken
by what Nick Fuentes had to say remember
this is before Christmas they had dinner
with him in Kanye West who again said he
loves Hitler he literally said it
himself on Alex Jones's show with Nick
Fuentes sitting there and he was
cheering him on yeah yeah okay so it
gets much much worse listen it's just
like my whole life my whole life
because I was always like the class
clown I was always like partying women
no well okay that part I believe women
women have always been like
simultaneously Charmed but also
uh like oh stop it oh oh you're so
annoying you know you know what I mean
telling him no
um saying no to him that's probably yeah
here let's this is one of those moments
where you like you watch on a show or a
movie right and somebody's telling their
version of the story right and so here
he's like oh no stop it you stop it just
stop playing like this is so for
flirtatious right and then the person's
like okay that's not at all how the
story like that's not at all how the the
thing went down this is how it really
went down and then you see the woman
being like no get the [__] away from me
dude stop it stop it stop it right
aggressively trying to be like get away
do not touch me do not talk to me
meanwhile you have Nick Fuentes who who
thinks in this like very uh
uh outdated way which is like if I stalk
the woman and I show up at her her place
of work or her school or if I
continually bother her and ask her it
means I really love her right and you
hear these stories all the time with our
grandparents are like oh well I mean I
showed up to her job and I I kept asking
around until she finally I wore her down
and she said yes you know Jesse Waters
like I slashed your tires so she
couldn't leave exactly right it was
awesome stories a lot great especially
from the right and so when you hear him
tell a story of like oh just stop it
don't get well stop it they're actually
aggressive get away from me stop get
away from me the [__] alone okay well
let's you know I I know that he says the
word rape all right this is I mean that
kind of thing
that's how women are with like uh with
this
with like my personality type or you're
like a rascal you know Rascal a rapist
and they're kind of like
because I'm like a rule breaker and
stuff yeah and so women simultaneously
are intrigued by that but they're also
they also have to pretend like they're
not because women it's sort of like how
women a lot of women want to be raped in
uh okay okay what so he just said he's a
rule breaker right which means he's a he
likes to break the law and then he says
you know how women want
again I want to remind everyone before
you hold that thought I want to remind
everyone Donald Trump had dinner with
this [__] and was he was
intrigued by him he's
flabbergasted by Nick Fuentes go ahead
keep in mind that Nick Fuentes is a
literal incel he said he's a virgin and
he's like I don't know what the big deal
of being a virgin is so when he says
this [__] right there is no woman I
guarantee there was no woman
that that plays around is like oh I Want
to Be Right shut the [__] up man shut
the [__] up any dude who says anything
like that like oh women are so sensitive
and you know they just love to be raped
and they love to no no we are not
[__] playing that game right now and
the idea that he wants to excuse any
poor or or malicious behavior
violent Behavior against a woman and
then be like oh you know what she was
asking for it she wanted it she wanted
it
these [__] the exact same type
of [__] that Trump pulls right all the
time
let's let's hear the end of this because
it's disgusting but listen he's talking
to an audience that is like not the
people at the In-N-Out Burger he's
talking to an audience that could be
riled up into some stupid [__] that they
would do and when I say raped I mean
like
that sounds bad when I say it like that
but there's like a lot of [__] you're
like I want a guy to beat the [__] out
of him oh God
but also they have to pretend but part
of it is they have to pretend like they
don't
they're gonna go they don't they they're
now it she was pretending Gabe she was
pretending that she didn't want Jesus
this is the same type of [__] when
someone's like oh you know she was the
victim of rape and somebody goes well
what was she wearing and you're like
what the [__] shut the [__] up man this
no do not try to excuse or Gaslight or
pigeonhole someone into something to be
like oh well they were asking for it or
they had it coming or you know what they
put it on themselves no no I also these
types of people it's it's his followers
it's it's Maga it's these right wing
incel white supremacist [__] cucks
that that try to excuse their terrible
terrible terrible Behavior and any time
a woman rejects them because they say
you're a piece of [__] I don't want
anything to do with you right you're
terrible for all of these reasons a
[__] long list of reasons then they
say oh you know what the only way to get
back to them is to show that I'm
powerful and then commit crimes against
them and say they really wanted it man
and it's like God damn dude it it
doesn't seem like it's a coincidence
that the same mindset you know he was
like guys like me Rascals
that they seem to be the ones who are
showing up in Nazi uniforms protesting
drag shows that they're the ones in
these state legislators that are trying
to legislate people out of existence
like Michael Knowles and Matt Walsh who
go on their shows on a daily who
demonize people for who they are
um it's the same ones who support Donald
Trump it's the same ones you say Alvin
Bragg is a George soros-backed animal
and just on and on with this nonsense
it's not surprising that these are all
one and the same people they are all
it's the same [__] that are
doing the same Nazi [__] it's this it's
the same once this is the same remember
this is the same [__] Nazi that
marjor Taylor green accepted to be a
speaker at their little event at CPAC in
2021 she's the one that went up there
and took oh yeah oh man oh man you guys
love the fact that people cancel us we
own it we're such a young audience
remember that he has a young audience
I'm just trying to make sure these these
young individuals aren't influenced with
bad things you mean the very thing that
you try to push every day the the
bigotry the white supremacy the the
anti-Semitism all of that stuff they
love you for those reasons and you know
that you know that 100 and you own it
and when you got called out for it then
you tried to save face but behind the
scenes
we all know the conversations that are
happening we all know we all know the
texts have come out you've have other
telegram chats or photos like the
internet doesn't forget and the people
that are watching know exactly who you
are on both sides they know exactly who
you are
well and we can't ignore this you know a
lot of people want to ignore this kind
of talk but this guy's talking to
thousands of stupid bastards just like
him that are going out in the world
thinking that they own the world and
they can do this [__] to other people
um in particular women and treat people
in the in the lgbtq community this way
uh the women this way that they don't
have rights and they don't have the
freedom of choice and and on and on it
goes and if you want these people in
power just go elect Donald Trump just do
that because he's intrigued by this he's
intrigued by this individual and what
they can do so I mean to bring it back
full circle is the same again is the
same type of behavior you treating a
woman poorly the same way that Donald
Trump goes oh stormy horse face Daniels
exactly same [__]
because she didn't like him and now he
has to to retaliate right and say oh you
know what uh she's ugly well and it's
the whole I'm famous they let me do that
exactly they like to be raped
but they really do they really do
everyone tomorrow's Friday tomorrow is
Friday which is bonehead of the week
yeah we also uh separately yeah from
bonehead we'll have our normal bonehead
Pole right but starting today we have uh
waiting down for the the Sinister 16
yeah because we're in the sweet 16 in
March Madness yeah bonehead Madness now
we have the Sinister 16 so we'll have
the uh the beginning uh
there's gonna be multiple polls there's
gonna be main one
and there's going to be other ones that
are happening where we'll finally get to
the bonehead Champion okay so so let's
um so everyone be looking for that where
you find that is on Twitter bonehead
Madness will be on Twitter but you can
vote for bone and the league on Twitter
you can also vote here on YouTube so
don't forget to subscribe it's free you
can go to the community tab you'll be
able to vote for bonehead of the week
later on this evening also download
every single episode on Apple Spotify
and Google and follow us on Facebook at
the Tony Michaels and also subscribe to
the up wires Channel we we broadcast
over there as well go to the upwire.com
Subscribe there and then link your
Amazon Prime account to Twitch you get
one free subscription you can give us
that subscription and we get a few bucks
of Jeff bezos's money every month and it
doesn't cost you a thing to give us
Jeff's money so do that and also go go
visit patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez he's
so close to his his goal of 50. he's so
close uh so I've got another uh I've got
another FaceTime call coming out today
it's going to be on patreon okay so you
got to go there first you gotta see it
but what's gonna happen is you're gonna
see a phone call between Donald Trump
yeah and myself oh Donald Trump
facetimed you this time so make sure to
go to patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez why
you're on patreon.com make sure to check
out my page the Tony Michaels just the
at patreon.com the Johnny Michaels and
you can you can see my page over there
uh thanks to everyone who's been members
over there the last few days and um I
posted a video yesterday on patreon um
of the a small clip of Jess Piper's
interview on Monday where she talks
about questioning people if they say
woke and I posted that clip on social
media today so everyone got an early
look yesterday on patreon but they you
saw it today on social media so go check
that video out too help me spread that
around we really appreciate having Jess
on this week not to talk to us and
hopefully uh she can come back to keep
us up to date on all the stuff that
these these right-wing Legends Slaters
are trying to do to your children's
education out there and and their labor
laws so check that interview out and I
actually posted on the YouTube channel
uh in and of itself so you can go watch
that interview just look for the Sarah
Huckabee sandals saying get a job kid
that's the one there yeah so go check
that video out and check the clip out
I've got the clip on YouTube as well so
everybody same time same place tomorrow
you know where the hell we are you know
what time it is
till then surfs that [__]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] them [__]
[Music]
's meal Barn head ass Beacon